welcome to the across the spoiliverse
podcast I'm your host Kevin feige as
always we are here talking about lots of
topics this week gonna hand it over at
my man Greg Albert Greg how's it going
it's going well I had a slump of a week
on YouTube you know how it goes my
friend Paul you you have like three to
four days of terrible views and then
you're like oh my God everything's
falling apart but we literally just
covered both you and I the craving the
hunter trailer and everything's back on
the swing I am feeling better about my
life overall now I think I'm ready to
keep moving on and continue this YouTube
Legacy we have built but speaking of
that we have four topics today uh that
I'm excited to dive into with you
because we have craving the Honda that
we're going to talk about since that
trailer just drops was feeling fresh in
the Noggin and then we have uh secret
Invasion First Reactions from which
surprised I don't know your opinion on
it did you you already saw it I'm
assuming
I saw episode one so when I'm doing
breakdowns and stuff I don't like to
jump too far ahead because one I forget
everything and then I have to go back
and re-watch it anyway and two I like to
do little Theory times you know what I
mean with theories and use my
imagination to guess what's gonna happen
whereas you know I don't want to drop a
video and be like here's all the things
that I think might happen next time and
they just turn out to be 100 right even
down to the clothes people are wearing
so I like to say that in this video but
we know he knows he does we know he does
that yeah and then of course we gotta
talk about
this did so much worse than we all
thought the flash box office and what
James Gunn ought to be doing next moving
forward but my friend Paul
um we only talked briefly on messaging
about craving the hunter uh I saw the
red band trailer got my video up what
did you think about it
I actually didn't see the red band
trailer because it leaked everyone in my
comment section because I posted the
trailer breakdown about 10 minutes after
the trailer released and they were
saying how the hell did you get this up
so quick um and it's because a version
of the trailer leaked on Twitter about
the hour before so I just started
working on that and then I did see
aspects of the the red band trailer
obviously I knew the whole thing was
going to be all right hidden to be
honest did it really add that much from
what I saw it was you know a couple of
gory shots and that was it
um the green band trailer of me just
basing my opinion off that it looked bad
didn't look very good uh I don't know
what the hell is going on with the lion
biting him and turning him giving him
Lions
is that what happens in real life it's
they're treating her like it's a
werewolf where a lion bites in as long
as you survive you get given crazy lion
Powers it's a radioactive line or some
[__]
I couldn't believe what I was watching I
was like wait a minute what are they
doing right now
but you know whenever they do this I
genuinely second guess whether my
knowledge is actually up to scratch
because I I'll do the best of my
knowledge Craven's not a meta human he
doesn't have any super powered abilities
but then I see that and I start thinking
crap is he actually because I have I'll
be honest with you I've not read every
single comic of quote that features
Craven from the last 60 years you know I
mean and there might be one out there
but um yeah just when I see stuff like
that I'm kind of thinking why have they
changed it and they've got their they've
got the morbius wall run that he does
he's Defying Gravity at points
um they've given it this Supernatural
twist ah I don't know if it needs it
there's also a bit where these spiders
dangle down and traumatize him in the
forest and I'm thinking is that why he's
got such a a dislike of Spider-Man
because he had some spiders traumatize
him in the forest it's a bit weird it's
all it's Sony isn't it they can either
make the best comic book movies of all
time I'm talking across the spider-verse
into the spider-verse the raymie trilogy
you know I mean or they can make the
worst comic book movies of all time and
you know which ones they are so yeah I
feel like this is gonna fall into the
latter unfortunately I'm sure it'll be
all right but wasn't that Blown Away by
the green band trailer and from what
you've said I'm guessing you enjoyed the
Red Band a bit more I'll say this I
forgot I was watching the red band
trailer and I'm pretty vocal when I'm
doing my reaction to it because I'm
having all the exact same thoughts that
you are
um lamenting in this very moment Paul
where the lion thing happened
actually right away I was like okay this
feels like a Sony Marvel movie and then
the lion thing happened I was like what
is going on and it was just like
laughing at what's happening
when the violence kicked in though that
did do something for me because to me
that I've always thought that even were
like Let There Be Carnage was failing it
could have made up for it by having some
really fun schlocky violence right just
some cool Gore and I thought the same
thing about morbius that that could have
helped elevate it to some extent and it
looks exactly like a Sony Marvel movie I
don't think it's going to be great I was
I was relieved though and I found myself
having fun so much fun with the fact
that they're actually committing to the
vi because it doesn't it really tampers
it whenever they do try to make these
edgy anti-heroes these people who were
like the actual characters who take time
or start off as villains and then
eventually are supposed to transition to
anti-heroes but they're just kicking
them off right away with being
anti-heroes that it it's a big
distraction of me a lot of the time when
they try to they try to put do like the
edgy PG-13 but you know that it's not
edgy it's just they're just not doing
the R rating and to commit to the R
rating for this especially for Craven
wall he's not going to be hunting
animals he's going to be a protector of
animals this time around at least when
he's slaughtering humans that's going to
be gory and bloody and it's not just
like some of the blood the blood looks
like CGI blend it looks schlocky and to
me I could actually see myself having
fun with this one do I think I
understand my expectation stations are
and I feel like you're probably the same
way I'm just a little more forgiving at
this point because my expectations are
so low for what to expect it was kind of
when I went into morbius I heard just
the worst things that the time I watched
it I was like ah I had a little bit of
fun I had fun laughing at it I didn't
hate it because like everyone else did I
could see it's a terrible movie but I
had fun watching it and I could see
myself having more fun watching this and
I believe this director is the one who
did triple Frontier which was an all
right action movie so I have a little
bit of I'm not gonna say I have hope
necessarily but I I think it'll be more
fun than what they did prior it isn't
you brought up the spider-verse movies
and it is fascinating how they can pull
off these
mesmerizing animated films with not just
mesmerizing you know uh animation but
stupendous storytelling on top of that
and yeah definitely and then on that's
my new favorite word I think and then uh
and then to see what they what they do
with these live actions like what are
all these live action ones look the
exact same they all they all feel and
look the exact same way but yeah Craven
doesn't have an accent there were things
about it that I'm not a massive craving
the hunter fan but with my familiarity
with it it's interesting that we're
going to be getting Craven in Marvel's
Spider-Man 2 the game which is a very
accurate depiction and then we're going
to be getting
this one so man man movie man the man
movie I think that it is good that they
are going rated with it because they
must have looked at the box office for
morbius and they toned it down so that
it would appeal to more people
um and it bombed so they must just be
thinking look
just do our rating it's probably
actually going to make more money by
being rated because
you know people are just gonna want to
go see it for all the blood and gore
which yeah
um I will go see it obviously you know
it's a for some reason I keep going back
to Sony movies and be like I'll see it
day one don't care if uh even if I don't
do a video I'm gonna do it day one so
yeah I think it's probably a smart move
by them wasn't Blown Away by the trailer
I think you can predict the entire plot
from watching this my guess is that his
brother who we see in the trailer
obviously he's the chameleon in the
comics guessing that he's gonna be
revealed to be the actual real villain
behind things but it's gonna be weird
the whole half human animal hybrid thing
they're doing and I really hope right I
really hope they don't do this but I
know for a fact they're gonna do it
they're gonna make the brother an actual
chameleon who can shape-shift and change
into people if they're going full-on
Rhino metamorphosis and lion gives you
lion Powers I think that's the way
they're gonna go and I hope they don't
but we have an animal world I'm excited
yeah
but we you got more in-depth thoughts
too on your video as as do we I got my
koi genre bringing all that comic book
knowledge so yeah you guys can go watch
our videos for we gotta talk about the
actual good juices I mean I feel like
the one we're going to be spending the
longest time on will probably be the
flash so let's talk about the secret
Invasion reactions I did already uh
cover my uh I had the privilege of being
able to film my reactions early for the
first two so
um I do have my opinion formulated I'll
just say this I really don't I have no
idea what your opinion is it's actually
kind of fun going in this I have no idea
what you thought
um but I I was before I give my opinion
I want to hear yours and then I'll just
follow suit with what do you think uh
I was surprised by
how low the critic score was for this
yeah
it was so it was it's like bordering on
Rotten and it's right there and there
was a there's a tidbit where it was
there
and it was the first time where I did I
found myself going through the capsules
being like wow I could not disagree more
with a lot of the people who are really
going against it talking about like Nick
Fury's board
um there's no it's not the fun Marvel
that we know I'm like these are all the
things that people did complain about
and I think that they are doing the
opposite of what typical Marvel is and
it's actually doing it well versus them
just doing the opposite for opposite's
sake so yeah I mean I'm getting kind of
hints of what you thought of the first
episode but I mean overall what did you
think about it well disclaimer
um I have only seen episode one so it's
a bit difficult to judge an entire show
of it but I thought it was really good
really enjoyed it
um I'm I'm very sick of the whole Marvel
thing they've been doing for the last
couple of years where it's like you can
tell they're just improvising on set and
just filming until they come up with
something funny and then they're like
right we'll cut it down and make the
scene with that bit doesn't have any of
that in still people are saying it's
completely humorless I disagree there's
an interrogation scene in it that's
quite funny
um you know Samuel L Jackson is very
very charismatic in it even when he's
playing stoic parts
it is very serious as well it's got a
very good undertone to it I started
working on my breakdown today lots of
really good things
um to talk about in it as well as you
know it starts off with quite a big
scene that there's a big revealing it
ends on a very big scene that there's a
really good thing that they close out on
and in between as well one thing that
Marvel movies have it sorry Marvel shows
haven't really done in the past is that
they've focused solely on the central
character so if you think about like Ms
Marvel or something you'll never cut to
a scene where it's just the villains
sitting about talking and planning
things or you know one division it it
took us up until episode four before we
even saw anything with sword
um Hawkeye as well you know you didn't
spend that much time with Echo there's
there's always this She-Hulk I had no
idea what was going on with Todd in that
uh the you know the other side of that
we we barely saw the the villains in it
at all
um until much later in the season
whereas here it's actually built like a
TV show in the fact that you've got
you're seeing different characters and
and the way they operate and connect I
thought the scroll stuff and that we get
introduced to very you know there's an
undertone to it you kind of get the
feeling like oh these guys could really
cause some serious issues and like I
said lots of really good things happen
in it
um Nick Fury he is kind of you know with
he does seem a bit worn out but I mean
this is episode one obviously that I'm
judging but I'm really intrigued and and
I couldn't believe that score after
watching the episode saw the score drop
uh so I knew you know what people's
feelings were and then I watched it
myself and then I was like hold on is
that really what it is like yeah I loved
it it's if you're into the Winter
Soldier
um Marvel actually taking themselves
seriously you know not just having
characters who like I'm a complete [__]
because that's what a lot of Heroes
these days seem to be it's like how
stupid can I be Shazam he's he actually
oh no he's DC but Shazam acted like a
[__] Thor acts like a [__] you know
the Guardians do it but they're they're
that is part of their character but I
feel like a lot of Heroes these days on
both sides The Flash as well that's
another example where they're just being
morons and just coming out with dumb
stuff and there's not those Heroes
anymore that you can really
aspire to want to be so for example Tony
Stark you know he he's busting jokes but
he's not the butt of the joke whereas I
feel like a lot of Heroes these days
they're making idiots of themselves so
that you laugh at them whereas this show
isn't doing any of that stuff and it's
taking everything really seriously
um it has you know jokes in but it's not
at the expense of the characters people
aren't getting humiliated so that you
laugh at them it's taking it all
seriously the threats really well placed
in and yeah I thought was good you know
every character in this show I feel some
sort of attachment to you know you don't
get introduced to that many but the ones
that you do even the villains I'm
thinking yeah this this guy's killing it
yeah I I agree I'm glad I'm relieved to
hear that I'm glad we see more eye to
eye on this than Craven the hunter
trailer
I was I was so surprised because
this you were talking about the humor
there is humor in it but the humor comes
from within the characters and their
personalities and they never feels like
they're just making jokes for the sake
of like doing a joke it never feels like
it's undercutting anything and is there
a lot of humor no but it just it feels
very natural whenever it's there it's
like the way a real human being would
have a sense of humor about things and
this show is more of a slow burn and I I
liken it I was it's easy to watch the
trailer and just think of oh it's kind
of like going back to the Winter Soldier
times it's a little bit more Espionage
than even Winter Soldier his winter
soldier still had more of that pulsating
excitement exciting action and crazy
choreography that they would do and
maybe that'll come later down the road
in the first two episodes that's not
really the case to me it was making me
think more of like an old school
Espionage film
um the like oh what was that Dustin
Hoffman it wasn't an Espionage film I
can't remember like that like All the
President's Men Tinker Taylor Soldier
Spy I got a lot of those vibes in there
too I don't know if you've seen those
but it has more of that debate element
throughout
and and to me it's very character driven
at the same time so while it's it's slow
it's not Meandering you know it's it's
not the way of like when you watch Iron
Fist and you go wow this is slow and
boring that's not the case they're
really doing a lot of build up here and
I think this is Samuel Jackson's best
work as Nick Fury the guy's so broken
and they flesh him out so well and
especially to get one of my favorite
things about the first two episodes and
it's demonstrated within the first
episode but when you watch the
combination of the first two is
um like I don't want to give any
specifics away you see in the trailer
that there's so many actors that are
going to be in the show you know you got
um Ben mendelsohn Sam Jackson Don
Cheadle John Cheadle Olivia Coleman and
what I love is that you get
genuine true scene work between them it
doesn't just feel like they're showing
up being charismatic or given a couple
lines like the scenes are so fleshed out
that it's often like this this duel
between them that's like cat and mouse
game between them as they're talking
there's there's trajectory there's
growth within the scenes there's there's
problem solving there there's real
investigating and it's figuring each
other out it's so well done that I found
myself it's been a while since I've been
like upset at a tomato score because
yeah because people look at that and
there doesn't even seem to be like any
gray opinion within of the people who
aren't recommending it you know
sometimes you can kind of go through it
and you're like oh okay well they Edge
towards rotten but it's not like
entirely rotten uh but it's people
there's these critics are like hating on
it and
I don't know maybe maybe they did
because it's not it's not exactly like a
super fun show it's not and but I I
think it's a it takes itself serious and
it's it's intriguing it's compelling and
there is the opening scene like you were
talking about
without giving it away sets the
groundwork so well of yeah I don't know
who a scroll is but it the show doesn't
necess solely rely on just that gimmick
you know they they really
yeah yeah it's not just about the
mystery it really is about the
characters
um at the same time they do keep the
plot moving forward and I could just if
they stick The Landing I was like two
episodes in I was like they stick The
Landing this might be the best Disney
Plus show that they've done and and then
to see uh See uh what the response was I
was like I can't I don't disagree I feel
like there's a lot of logic and sound
reasoning behind you know a lot of times
the the thing people fall back on is you
know uh like oh you're just a [__] you
know if we're defending it is like
you're just the shill and no that's bad
storytelling and you're just looking at
it because it's fun and I'm like I
wouldn't even say this show is fun uh I
I like it for how compelling it is and
how this is the kind it feels like cable
television you know so yeah I like the
times for the characters you really feel
it through it and I yeah I was I really
enjoyed that that episode my wife fell
asleep but it was late on to be fair so
maybe that's an indication of the
general audiences but if I I I really
enjoyed it
um you know my people keep saying I'm a
Negative Nancy when it comes to Disney
Plus shows because I tend to have my
criticisms for them but you know I would
rather watch something like this over
the
those comedies in quotation marks that
we've had where some stuff's funny but
you know what it's just kind of
very low-key and whereas this feels like
an actual proper threat yeah I feel like
something bad could definitely happen
here and you get that from the first
episode there's two very big scenes that
happen in it and yeah you just kind of
get the feeling oh crap there's almost
no like you know the Dark Knight it's
not on the Dark Knight level but you
know how there's that gradual build
throughout the Dark Knight and you
constantly get that feeling of dread as
it ramps up and the longer things go on
you kind of get that feeling with this
as well where it starts off very low-key
you know the the scene has been shown
um on YouTube they they dropped the
first five minutes of it they didn't
show some of the things that go into it
but it starts off kind of low-key with
just two characters meeting and then
things just build from there and get
worse and worse and worse and then once
you meet the villains as well they
really help to give the idea that
there's a threat here it's not just kind
of in cells trying to embarrass She-Hulk
and steal her powers you know what I
mean these are people who have genuine
reasons as well for why they feel let
down and to me the Scrolls in this are
like the really good version of the flag
smashes yeah I mean you can kind of
appreciate why they're doing what they
do and
almost be like oh man these guys are
quite dangerous yeah because the whole
thing is just like you don't know who
could be a scroll and it's not guilty of
what a lot of Marvel shows have done
where they kind of tease the villain
like I remember they had a scene with
vincentonofrio's Kingpin that was
originally supposed to be in episode
three of Hawkeye but they were so used
to doing these things where it's like oh
no if we tease a villain and have the
the person working behind the scenes
controlling it all like we saw with one
division you know the audience is going
to come back and they're going to
speculate and come back week to week and
they did the same thing with the power
broker as well and then they purposely
edited Kingpin out of Hawkeye to kind of
get people to come back they haven't
done that yet the mystery is still like
oh who who do we trust but it's not like
uh it doesn't feel like they're cutting
things out to make you come back the
next week everything's on screen here
and you're you know you're you're kind
of trying to figure things out really
really enjoy that first episode probably
by episode four would be like oh same
old same old they're dropping the ball
yeah
but we'll say I am excited to see how it
goes and I'm looking forward to covering
it uh for the next six weeks yeah man
yeah okay I'm excited to see you hit
trending all the time for the next six
weeks but on the complete opposite
Spectrum we had a very very very
different kind of comic book property
come out
um and we we already did our last
podcast talking about how it's looking
like it's going to flop
and
who did worse than did a lot worse than
a lot of people
usually that goes up a little bit and
this went down like significantly and
that is of course with the flash uh it
opened to just like 55 million in the
states which is way under projections
they were supposed to they were
projecting like 65 to 75 million and
there's a lot of things that can factor
into it
um and then the other side of it that
one thing that we were really I think
the thing we spent the most time talking
about was Howard because we know what
it's like to be plugged into this
specific Zeitgeist on the internet and
then you know the what the movie sphere
is often talking about or we're
factoring in like Ezra Miller in
Connected universes and all these things
and would this affect General audiences
and then when I saw that the Rotten
Tomatoes audience score was like 85 I
was like oh my God this might be bad
then I looked it up and the cinema score
was a b which is the lowest out of the
DC films and that surprised me I didn't
think it would actually come in as as
the lowest of the like I think that I
think a cinema scorer is more reliable
to see what audiences think and feel
than in Rotten Tomatoes audience score
uh so the cinema score was much more
indicative of oh this is just not
clicking with people this is just not
going over though I I thought that this
would actually be perceived in a in a
more positive light amongst audiences at
least the beat plus uh and apparently
it's just not it's not driving so it's
probably not going to have legs
uh what are your thoughts on this map
how do you feel this honestly right and
like I I'm quite a big Snyder fan I'm
not gonna harass you online yeah if you
I'm not gonna spend my days arguing with
you about Zack's not his movie and
trying to force you to enjoy them but I
enjoy his films and I do think they
mishandle a lot of things I was excited
to see Henry Cavill back obviously stuff
happened with that he got kicked to the
curb he didn't get fired according to
the stories but he didn't get hired
um you know we had the things with
Wonder Woman and a lot of the things
that I was starting to get invested in
and feel like oh maybe they're turning
things around again like Ben Affleck
appearing in Aquaman too I was thinking
you know what they're they're going back
to this they dropped the ball with that
and I just saw oh man like
I just can't be bothered with these
movies I hopes you know they flop but
honestly seeing what's happened with the
flashing Warner Brothers it actually
makes me feel pretty sad when I saw that
55 million number of it was like they
they did a point one so it was like 55.1
million I'm like oh that that point
one's doing a lot of work there and I
just felt bad because obviously Warner
Brothers they're in a lot of financial
trouble as it is and I actually went
back right and I looked at all of the DC
EU movies since Aquaman there's I think
there's been seven or eight since then
and they've all lost money none of the
DC EU films since Aquaman have made over
400 million dollars and that's not you
know that's box office gross that's not
even taken into account how much they
spend on the money how much marketing
costs so things like birds of prey
Suicide Squad Wonder Woman 84 Shazam and
Shazam two
The Flash obviously and I'm sure there's
something else in there that I'm Black
Adam there we go so so that's seven it's
good worse than Black Adam it's the
worst yeah none of those hit 400 over
400 million which is absolutely crazy to
have that many flops in a row
it's telling you that people aren't
interested in this at all and I'm
starting to Guess that if you total up
the number that the dcu's cost that it's
lost them more than it's made because
there's just been so many bombs back to
back and I think in general this is
going to have a massive effect on the
industry I think studios are going to
start to tighten their budgets on these
films going forward they're big risks at
this point because they're spending a
lot and if they don't make it back that
is a big problem
um and I just feel like it's sad that
it's turned out this way but when you
keep going for quantity like this which
the studios are doing they're trying to
do as many comic book movies as they can
because they used to be the big bankable
things you're going to run into these
issues and I think James Gunn just needs
to hard reset everything we'll talk
about this more later on but it's
clearly not the interest there with the
audience and it's it's crazy to me that
there's been seven flops like that in a
row like absolutely crazy easy remember
back in the day before shared universes
we're in our 30s so we remember movies
yeah if you did a movie and it did well
it got a sequel if you did if the sequel
did terrible they didn't make a third
film right that was it the franchise was
over
and they're so invested in these shared
universes at the moment that even when
stuff's bombing they're still like no we
have to keep making more we have to we
have to keep striking until we we get a
home run and it's like mate just read
the writing on the wall no one's like
Aquaman 2 is not going to do well
Blue Beetle don't think that's gonna do
well I think studios are just too tight
to their shared universes at this point
that someone at Warner Brothers should
have realized by the the second or third
flop something's going on here we need
to pump the brakes sort everything out
and instead that's like they're still
going I get they canceled Batgirl they
probably saw what was going to happen
with that
but for it to do this badly it's
absolutely crazy now why do you think
the main issues are obviously number one
it Ezra Miller is going to be giving a
lot of blame for this but I personally
don't think that it's all on their
shoulders I just
don't think the blame Falls solely at
their feet I don't think audiences give
a I don't think General audiences
care as much about the Ezra Miller stuff
as most of us do here in this in this
field I I don't think so
um yeah I feel like most of them are
like aware like that they might hear
something but they don't really keep up
with the details of these things unless
you're like a super invested fan and and
even even with that I still feel like
even if you I'm sure there are people
who have decided I'm not going to watch
it because of Ezra Miller I regardless
of whatever your opinion is of whoever's
listening to this
it's I think it's pretty obvious most
people will still watch it like they
won't let that of be the determining
Factor on whether or not they're going
to watch it I could see it being I did
not like the flash character uh I didn't
like the way Ezra Miller portrayed The
Flash so I don't care to watch this
movie because you know like justice
league if you think about it you know I
don't really know for General audiences
how many of those people
saw Justice League the Joss Whedon
version and then
heard about Zack Snyder's Justice League
and went all right I'll go and watch
that I don't know how many of those
people converted to watching that to go
wow Ezra Miller's so much better here I
will I'm interested now in The Flash and
I think that I think that was confusing
in marketing for people where the
universe the way this universe has been
built up
has been just so iffy and all over the
array of it has been all over the place
and it's it's heavily reliant on this
the trailers rely on the Nostalgia for
for Man of Steel but then they're also
telling audiences That Man of Steel
doesn't matter anymore because Henry
cavill's not around and yeah and then
they're confused by the Batman of what's
going on there and I'm wondering how
much the Nostalgia for Michael Keaton's
truly holds up for people I I don't I
think are indicative of it that it
doesn't really hold up as strong for
Michael Keaton because
I think our standard of superhero has
really like Michael Keenan I've never
said is is my favorite Batman like I've
always enjoyed Michael Keaton but I've
I've more preferred the movie world he
inhabits more than I prefer the Michael
Keaton portrayal of Batman and Batman
has become so definitive on on what's
required to be Batman you know with
um you know the body build and the body
movement uh so it's like cool to see him
but it is like eh my old guy Michael
Keaton's playing bad like there was I
thought that I thought W in all honesty
I feel like WB did the absolute best
they could with their marketing foreign
well we got a lot working against us we
got Ezra Miller we got James Gunn who's
trying to make it sound like that this
movie does matter and and James Gunn is
giving this like proud thing but him
saying that you know we're going to be
resetting everything
does make it feel inconsequential and
they really did their best I thought
they delivered great trailers overall
the trailers were very exciting what
they did
at the end of the day though they it's
they still did not convey that this is a
a movie you must watch this is a movie
you you need to see at the end of the
day and yeah you know most people are
willing to wait now unless I I thought
that people who did go to the theaters
and catch each others might want to see
it but perhaps the the spectacle of it
still did not look
all that entirely uh enticing as and as
a must watch to see on the big screen
because it as I thought maybe the visual
experience would do it but then then I
think the word of mouth on the other
side of it that I'm thinking about too
for for General audiences is that the
you know a big part of like a
justification to go to the theaters now
is for spectacle and what does the
spectacle feel like and look like and
the most common consensus about the CGI
you know is that it's terrible and I
think that word of mouth just spread
like wildfire that it doesn't look good
you know so you don't need a seat on the
big screen because the CGI doesn't look
that good so you you can just wait uh
yeah and if it's not it's a bummer for
the for the film but it's I thought I
really did think it would do a little
bit better uh yeah I thought it would do
way better yeah I think obviously that
with the marketing you know we're saying
it's not Ezra's fault but obviously it
doesn't help the movie either that they
can't promote it out yeah and Ezra can't
do any of the marketing for the film so
they obviously had to do lots of weird
things like let Tom Cruise come see the
movie early uh James Gunn constantly
saying it's I'll listen to the Michael
Rosenbaum podcast with him last week and
he didn't even say it's the greatest
comic book movie of all time he said
it's one of the greatest movies of all
time yeah which uh and they kind of over
marketed the entire thing I think they
had so many early screenings and giving
away basically seats for free for months
and months and months and the difficulty
is when you have the hype and the
reactions lift so early that it's
difficult to maintain attain that until
the film releases because you know the
the reactions have came out oh
everyone's excited and then how do you
keep that that buzz up for for months
it's so difficult to do it because the
internet you know things come in dark
like you'll have a massive show on the
internet we'll be doing videos on it
we'll be getting a million views per
episode breakdown on something like
House of the Dragon you know what I mean
and then once it ends two weeks later
you try and make a house of the dragon
video it bombs yeah you'll be very
surprised at how quickly interesting
something dies off and that was clearly
the case in this movie with uh how early
they did the the hype you've also like
you said before you know Zack's not as
Justice League I absolutely love the
film but I know a lot of people think
it's just a four hour version of the
2017 film because even if you go back
and watch that it's still got directed
by Zack Snyder on it so people kind of
probably just think it's like a
director's cut of that even though the
tones completely different a lot of the
scenes are completely different it's
obviously got two hours more stuff which
is like a whole movie of extra content
people don't really understand that
and I think to them they think that the
flash is a sequel to that too that the
flash is basically a character from that
2017 movie who is sort of also a
character from this thing on HBO Max or
whatever and it's starring a problematic
actor who is playing a character that
they don't really like that much and you
know there's a TV version of this
character that's a lot more popular and
there's so much stuff going on and even
selling it on Batman
I mean there's people who this what
should have been DC's no way home but it
didn't even it didn't have that stature
to it because you had Michael Keaton
coming back you had Ben Affleck coming
back you had Gal Gadot but Toby Maguire
Andrew Garfield Willem Dafoe Alfred
Molina Jamie Foxx
Thomas Hayden Church maybe he's not a
big massive office box office draw you
know what I mean but that he had far
more Heavy Hitters and big names in no
way home and then yeah it's just Michael
keatony's obviously not as popular as we
perceive him to be because the the kids
aren't down with them that I think if
they'd got Bail back it would have been
way bigger astronomical would have been
nasty yeah yeah
they didn't so you're kind of dealing
with Michael Keaton who he's an older
Batman
you know maybe the kids aren't fully
down with him but he's kind of carrying
the entire thing on his shoulders like a
lot of the the push for the flashes go
see Michael Keaton back as Batman and
maybe people just aren't interested in
that like they're clearly not so yeah I
also think that Superhero fatigue in
general
played into this massively you know we
we've seen this across the board all
year where superhero movies have been
underperforming and the Multiverse in
general is becoming a bit of a tired
concept we've had no way home obviously
that was massive Doctor Strange in the
Multiverse Madness pretty good but you
could start to see a decline then you
had obviously
um across the spider versus released
earlier this month brilliant movie it
sucked a lot of the wind out of the room
in terms of what the flash was gonna do
and you also have big oscar-winning
films you know Best Picture Winner
everything everywhere all at once we've
had a number of Multiverse movies so far
that have all either done really well at
the box office or they've been
critically acclaimed and then this just
feels like oh they're doing the
Multiverse thing again rather than be
like we've got a fresh take on it you
know it's just kind of oh we're bringing
back old actors and there's a character
who can travel the Multiverse and you're
gonna see some cameos which they leaked
online as well Greg what were your
thoughts on those cameos I don't think
I've spoke to them spoke to you about it
what what did you think because I'm I
was very uh I don't like that yeah I
hated it you're talking about the uh
like I mean we could just talk spoilers
right you're talking about like the in
the what is it called what was that
thing called the core or something
if you don't want spoilers if you've
somehow managed to avoid all of the
spoilers which were posted out of
context on Twitter which was another
thing that was against this film
obviously that big clip of The Flash
microwaving a baby that blew up and got
reported by a lot of things even though
it was reversed but it's weird anyway
putting like a baby in a microwave
anyway so you know there was weird stuff
going on there but obviously the cameos
have been spoiled everywhere I knew
about them before seeing the movie
because they were posted all over to her
because Warner Brothers decided to hold
thousands and thousands of screenings
and not get people to sign ndas and just
inviting everyone and obviously the
general public they're not like us
they're not like us classy critics Greg
they'll uh they'll just go into secret
screenings and film stuff on their
phones so yeah what were your thoughts
on the cameos
you know the thoughts in the cameos
actually led me to think about another
reason why this might not work so my
quick thoughts on the on why this movie
might not just appeal to people so quick
thoughts on the cameos
um the at the end I I am not I've seen
it twice and both audiences uh freak out
when Christopher Reeve shows up
um Nick Cage shows up uh and George
Reeve which was pretty controversial for
a lot of reasons um
I don't freak out because it just
doesn't look real to me it they just
animated them in there and they don't
even have like a line you know they
don't feel like an actual character at
all I think the Nick Cage one is is the
coolest one of them all but whenever it
does the face reveal it just pulls me
out yeah it doesn't feel tangible and
supposedly Nick Cage did actually shoot
something for it and I'm like well then
why didn't you to have him say something
that way it feels like authentic in some
way yeah versus just Superman cutting to
hit Superman doing something and then
Superman just watching bad things happen
without actually getting involved like
they don't feel like characters there
and it's just this it's it's it's it's
in some ways a cooler looking version of
the email exchange in bvs that everyone
bitched about with you know opening up
these files but at least they were there
this is like they're they're just
animated like any YouTuber it could just
animated something into there and the
and on top of that the animation looked
terrible it didn't look good at all so
when you I was hearing that Nick Cage
was in there I was that he actually
filmed something that shocked me because
it felt like they just could have put
anyone there and then thinking about
cameos I think they teasing the trailers
that Zod is supposed to be like an
actual villain
um in this movie and I get like the
actual villain of the movies like time
and consequences whatever but in terms
of like the physical human uh
um uh you know like the physical threat
of being Zod
he is just a glorified Cameo and
and I hated the way Zod was handled in
here I thought Zod I got I got kind of a
a trickle effect here where I'm going
with this point I felt like Zod really
needed a bit of a Thanos treatment of
what they did in Avengers end game uh
not a yeah with end game because in
endgame you know Thanos dies but then
they reintroduced Thanos to reset up the
threat that way when he shows back up in
the finale it still has stakes and it
still has tension and you the threat is
so palpable we're here it's it's just it
really relies on you being like knowing
Man of Steel so fresh in your mind like
as if you just watched it so that way
you could feel the threat that's all
being developed off screen and for a
while I actually had the question if
Michael Chan was actually there
and as this ripple effect is going
backwards it made me go Man of Steel at
least Had An Origin tale and it had a
Zod origin tale and I think when you're
seeing the trailers for Flash it's
relying so much on Barry changing the
past and the consequences of that and
him interacting with his younger self
and that I don't think is like we
understand what's going on because we
know the story of Barry Allen and maybe
perhaps people who've watched the
television show know the story of Barry
Allen but that's relying on a lot of
people knowing the other IP of Like
Comics or a show I think when you're
watching like the trailers for this it's
not that exciting because we didn't get
to experience the origin of this Barry
Allen on screen so to then do the it
goes back to the exact thing that people
were already apprehensive about with
doing a Flashpoint adaptation right away
is that they did not build to a
Flashpoint adaptation they just hop
straight to Flashpoint and then they're
like they're make I thought it worked
within the movie of of going to the past
and understanding what Barry Allen's
history is uh but the audiences didn't
get to experience that so it's not
exciting when you do that it's like the
same thing with it's a magic they just
like hop to end game then they're going
to like New York City and these other
things in 2012 but we didn't get to
experience that so it's not the reason
if it's effective in endgames because
that's exciting that we're going back to
something we already experienced and
we're watching these things were being
revised and changed and you don't get
that with audiences in this movie so I
think actually hopping straight to
Flashpoint might have been their biggest
mistake with handling the flash on the
big screen
yeah I definitely agree I think I'm
actually working on a video at the
moment uh called dear Hollywood please
stop doing this and it's just talking
about bringing dead actors to for Cameo
points I think we've kind of you know
hit the point now where you're just
desecrating their grave and bringing
them back to life so in in the video I
basically talk about all the times that
you know the history of bringing back
dead actors and how it started uh the
first real instance I could find was
Game of Death with Bruce Lee who sadly
passed away during the making of the
film and they had to use body doubles
cardboard cutouts of him and and edit
him into the film and they've actually
filmed parts of Bruce's real life
funeral uh yeah first in which the
character fakes his own death and that's
kind of getting into the morally gray
area now
that you then you know Jump Ahead a
couple of years couple of decades you
get to things like Grandma talking and
and the reason you know whenever I bring
up doing dead bringing back dead
celebrities they always say oh well you
don't get mad about Disney doing it and
Rogue one I feel that there there's a
character there it's integral to the
plot it makes sense you know Paul Walker
it the ending of fast and Fast and the
Furious seven that's a tribute to him it
actually feels like they're doing
something whereas here it's just a case
of flashing them on screen just so
easily manipulated audiences point and
go whoa whoa look at the it's on it's
the person I love like I could easily
get a picture of Christopher Reeve deep
fake it and have him flash on screen
right now
it didn't it doesn't mean he's actually
in our video you know what I mean this
they haven't really done the work there
and when it it just looks so bad I think
you're completely right about the camera
movements as well there's something
weird about it where it goes to their
face and then spins around and it's just
like it looks so unnatural even from the
way the camera moves and I just found it
really disrespectful obviously George
Reeves is another thing where the actor
was a Superman ruined his life basically
he went into a massive depression off
the back of it and
there's no way he couldn't send it to
this he doesn't have children
he when he was making Superman that
there's no way he would have even been
able to imagine being brought back
through computers and put into a film
like this so it feels like there's no
way he could have consented when it
comes to people like Harold Ray missing
Ghostbusters afterlife he at least
wanted to make Ghostbusters 3 you know
he worked on it for years never got it
off the ground and they built the movie
up as a tribute to him whereas this it
just feels like they've just said you
know can you make the a CGI character
look like Christopher Reeves and George
Reeves yeah we can cool how does it look
it doesn't look that good mate it looks
a bit PS3 can I work on it longer no I
just just put it in anyway and it just
it just you sat there looking at the bad
effect thinking about that more than the
actor uh it's it's like when they they
unveil a statue of of someone and you
know the statue is really bad you don't
think oh wow what a touching tribute you
think no that statue looks terrible so
that's how I felt about it and I
completely agree about Zod as well
um I think Thanos in endgame the one
that comes back at the end actually
feels like a bigger threat because he's
younger he's he knows the future he
knows how to go around things he just
wants to kill everyone this time instead
of just half the universe that feels
really good whereas Zod they kind of
dropped the ball with the villain of
this movie and couldn't really promote
it as much as they could have if they'd
actually written one specifically for
the film one thing that I don't get why
they didn't do is have Barry see the
reverse flash kill his mother
because Barry doesn't even try to see
who killed this bike yeah like Argos my
mind like you just after you drop after
you fix the cans try to see who killed
your mom yeah like you're in in the
present day you're trying to get your
dad freed for from the murder of your
mother yeah surely knowing this will
help in that court case like knowing
that now I did give the the movie an
eight out of ten I said in my review
I'm kind of going between a seven and an
eight but I'm gonna round it up because
I feel
good coming out of the film I'm sure
when I re-watch it I'll enjoy it but
just as I've had more time to think
about it and seen
everything it's just it has kind of
dampened the experience for me and the
the way they're sort of going with the
future of the DCU as well I'm starting
to think I'm not that confident about
what's coming down the line and that
kind of takes us into our next topic is
James Gunn doing the right thing
I personally think the guy has blown it
a number of times I think he shouldn't
have said anything about these movies no
longer mattering before they'd actually
released I think that was a stupid thing
to do to come out and be like look we're
starting a new DCU it's all this stuff
we're we're kind of brushing it to the
side but make sure you go see those
movies some stuff's gonna matter some
stuff's not I think that was a very very
stupid thing to do and it's potentially
cost them hundreds of millions of
dollars
I I think Gunn needs to learn to just
not announce things
when he doesn't need to and it's the
case with Annie machete as well they've
announced him as the Brave and the bowl
director before even seeing how this
movie does and seeing how it's received
which is absolutely crazy like there's
no you have has that story even blown up
that much it's not really went down you
know it's not broke the internet
I think they needed to just hold things
off
take it easy see how stuff goes and then
answer it like saying Blue Beetle is the
first hero in the DCU
he he said that and that you have no
idea how the film's gonna go like how
can you walk that back if it's bad Grace
Randolph did a brilliant video on it
just talking about all the ins and outs
of it and she that was one of the points
she made was you it's going to be
difficult to walk that back if Blue
Beetle does badly you're starting it's
like when they started off phase five
without man Quantum Mania starting off
on the wrong foot if it goes badly
yeah I think they should really for Blue
Beetle because they have that line about
Batman and stuff in there and I think
you should just not rely on any of that
I'm like no you gotta come make people
not think about any of that moving
forward I love the I mean I I did love
the podcast he did with Michael
Rosenbaum um I listened to the whole
thing yesterday I was working on some
thumbnails and
I still have fate like if if there's
anything that I have the most faith in
what James Gunn's going to do
the way he talks about his craft the way
he's creating a crafting Superman
that is the thing that I'm actually I it
has completely made me because you and I
have talked about it even even here
about how we're not entirely sure if
James Gunn is the
right person you know to do to to helm
to actually Helm the movie himself yeah
that podcast and understanding a little
bit more of his intent and how he
approaches things
and what allowed him to actually you
know decide to pull the trigger on him
doing it that gave me that reinst it's a
great if you haven't heard it guys you
should listen to it it's a great podcast
it actually gets really personal too
about uh his mindset in life and I
thought it was really insightful and
introspective
so yeah I mean I think moving forward
the way they because obviously a big
controversial thing been coming out was
that they changed the ending of this was
originally Michael Keaton in The Flash
and then Supergirl supposed to be there
I believe Henry Cavill was supposed to
be a Wonder Woman it's supposed to be a
whole big thing at the very end
and um they changed that which I think
was really good so that way you don't
have to worry about anything else for
The Flash coming forward the the
question I was Raising was like is this
me George Clooney will be Andy
muschiety's Batman I don't think so I
think I think that was just a joke
um yeah it was but it's just so
confusing like yeah why end on that note
if so is Ezra Miller and Co are they
just off in the George Clooney verse
that's
somewhere off in the Multiverse where
it's not really connected but they're
living their life with all the guys who
love messing around and joking I mean
you brought this up in your video too
and I thought it as well I was like I
thought George Clooney was the same
Batman as Michael Keaton but apparently
not and uh Coy was telling me that they
had the Alfred line because the Alfred
is the the thing that stays constant in
the spaghetti I'm like this is just this
is too much I don't I don't care I'll
just I'll just separate the two
what James Gunn needs to do is because
this goes back to a point you were
making earlier about all the dceu movies
bombing
the the only ones that did not bomb were
the ones not connected to the DC EU
Joker and the Batman
and I think that whatever he does
especially for Superman
I think that's going to be this best
that it made
seeing the trajectory of the box office
it made the most sense to me now why
they had to start fresh and as much as I
wanted to see Henry Cavill carry on I
feel bad for him and so like I've I've
expressed this sentiment so much of the
time and it really is a bummer and the
way the handling of him is awful like it
can't be reiterated enough it really is
awful
and you're looking at it from a business
standpoint and the way the films are
going and everything
and you want us and you want to make a
clear-cut universe yes starting with
the most like one like next to Batman of
course but the most iconic symbol of
them all is being Superman with the DC
Universe and then that getting a new
face a new thing everything new and you
get that trailer it's just it's
instantly communicating for even General
audiences
this is brand new this is a brand new
start and that trailer needs to
communicate everything that like so much
comes down to the trailers and that
trailer needs to communicate literally
everything that James Gunn sets out to
do with the movie and this and the good
story comes first because even if the
movie doesn't isn't a huge
isn't huge on opening and needs to have
the best goddamn word of mouth so that
way he could still have legs and box
office numbers for a while Blue Beetle
saying it's the first I still see I
could see Blue Beetle carrying on and
whatever interconnectivity there is if
blue beetles even I'm saying even if
Blue Beetle ends up being a flop the
character could still carry on in a
Jaime Reyes and still carry on in other
ways and whether it be crossovers or in
the Booster Gold show or whatever like
he could somehow still exist and be
there similar to The Hulk and how he had
a solo movie and now he just shows up in
other people's [__]
so I could see why you can confidently
be like no I still want uh cholo to be
is it cholo so it's for him to be uh
Jaime Reyes and stick around
but the first official one being the DCU
Superman
yeah uh I think everything's gonna come
down to that whenever that trailer comes
out like after Aqua Aquaman 2 is the
last one right so after Aquaman too they
just need a race Creature Commandos
Creature Commandos is the first
I don't think they're going to be as
stupid that's not it's stupid let's be
honest it's launching a universe with
creature Commando as your first an
animated movie is your first film when
you're doing a live-action audience uh
live action Universe it's pretty stupid
I mean they're saying they're doing lots
of great animation styles with it it
might be the next into the spider-verse
sure but
it's launching a universe with that to
me it's stupid I think you know the
writings on the wall we talked about
this earlier in the the video seven
films since Aquaman nine DC films all
together the seven that bombed were
connected to the the DC EU the two that
didn't are off for doing their own thing
this shows you that you don't need to
rely on the DC EU and in fact it's
probably gonna hold the movie back so I
I like I said the writing is on the wall
there
the successful ones are off doing their
own thing they're not connected to this
so you don't need it just cut it off I
think guns should hard reboot everything
I think unfortunately he's gonna have to
make some tough choices and get rid of
his own characters but he doesn't seem
to want to so peacemakers coming back
Wallace coming back you're still gonna
have these ties to that old Universe
which I I think they need to be severed
and I love the dceu I've had fun 10
years watching it but at this point it's
not bringing the audience in fact it's
likely just putting people off and I
think as long as you're tied to that
it's gonna hold you back so please go
and just cut it off start again if
launch with Superman as its own thing
the same way that Matt Reeves launched
with the Batman the same way that Todd
Phillips launched with Joker Just Launch
with its own thing and build out from
there I I think the mistake that
happened a lot of times people take the
wrong lessons from things that are
successful when we saw Studios do it
constantly DC is a big victim of it too
with after seeing Marvel
they're like he's shared Universe keep
telling people that let's just keep it
yeah keep honing it on a shared universe
I'm sorry
you know I was thinking the other day
that everyone slags DC off for being too
dark and stuff but if you look at all
the the movies that have done well for
DC they're all dark movies yeah I think
people just genuinely want this tone
from DC that they try and go for the
well I suppose Aquaman obviously that's
not really a dark film that and Wonder
Woman's not they're kind of the
exceptions to the rule but every time DC
actually does a very dark film it does
well well trilogy
original Batman stuff the Batman Joker
all did well dark dark films they don't
need to do this thing that Marvel's
doing well I I think he's just brought
up Aquaman and
I feel like the people who are already
gonna comment this retort are not going
to make it this far but how we were
talking about how oh people you know
like the flash was in freaking Justice
League and that was forever ago and and
no one really liked it and and then her
bringing the flash back
but Aquaman did so well and that was
from the same movie Aquaman was still
hey Aquaman was more recent in release
to that and B the trailer if you go back
to those trailers for Aquaman it was
still like this is different this is
unique this is something that we haven't
seen before and it had this worldwide
appeal because of this crazy world in
the universe that it was building
it was so strange and I think when you
look at like the Batman as many Batman
things as we got that trailer was it had
a vision it had a distinct voice about
it Joker same exact thing it's not just
the fact that these characters are there
like yes it's easy to go well it's
because it's Batman and Joker but I
really think a lot of it also comes down
to the fact of what this trailers
communicated and like that's the thing
working against Blue Beetle I think is
that at the end of the day like it looks
really fun it doesn't look exactly like
hyper unique if it looks like a
um derivative of a lot of other comic
book movies already like it looks cool
it looks like a lot of it looks fun to
me but it doesn't look a hundred percent
unique
and
even if you think about that first Man
of Steel trailer like wow this is a very
different Superman this looks
interesting and I think James Gunn's DCU
every one of their new movies like the
movies I think are going to be more of a
testament to how this is going to pan
out than Creature Commandos
because a lot of people are not just
going to Care to tune in for the show
might have good word of mouth whatever
but I I agree it's not the smartest
first step to be looked this is the
first official launch I think Superman
will be a bigger Testament than anything
else and it that's what needs to be
that's why I keep going back to that
trailer is that that's what needs to
communicate is that this has to have a
vision to it and not just feel familiar
and I think at the end of the day
The Flash movie trailers relied so much
on familiarity like that's the whole
point of the trailers Zod
Super Man of Steel Batman you know
everything about it was solely reliant
on familiarity instead of something
unique where even the Guardians 3
trailer felt more unique uh the the
spider it's spider verse like how it
does get more unique than that you know
and and that's the main thing that I
think
we really need right now like even
Shazam for the gods the trailers felt
generic and passable yeah really bad so
I remember watching that thinking I've
literally seen this film seven times
before definitely and yeah just a hero
losing their powers kind of getting them
back yeah it's doing generic superhero
stuff and I think gun
I think creatively he has the the right
mind state to be able to do it I just
don't think that he's a very good
Hollywood exec I don't even just arguing
with people on Twitter it feels like
someone's had a word with him and that
he started to Reign it in a bit because
he there's not really been that many
rumors debunked and it's gotten to the
point where did you see the the Superman
Legacy auditions were announced the
other day yeah the people who were they
were con who they were currently casting
Gunn didn't come out and debunk it and
the fact that he's debunked so many
Rumors in the past now makes the ones
that he doesn't debunk seem legitimate
because he's not out doing it and that's
the thing with Kevin foggy you'll never
see him pop up on Twitter and argue with
someone like Josh of our dinner nerds
you know I I would speak the guy all the
time
um and I was laughing when he got dunked
On by gun I was going are you idiot he's
just embarrassed you but looking back I
don't really think that as a CEO of a
studio should be tweeting Josh from
denim nerds to making fun of him for
like living in his mom's basement and
stuff you know what I mean it it
distracts from the product and the
biggest issue that dz's had is the drama
there's been constantly just headlines
about how badly the studio is
mishandling things Ezra made things
worse obviously well I don't even know
if it was so much Ezra it's just kind of
the the aura and I mean a lot of those
stories are getting debunked now and
then things like that and it's obviously
the Press is gonna just pick up on the
things that they're hearing and try and
make the biggest story out there because
it's going to get them clicks and they
know that DC is an easy target because
of this due to the fact of how much
mismanagement there is and how many
times Executives say one thing and then
do the other and
that there's such a bad atmosphere and
air around DC at the moment that I
really hope that Matt Reeves I hope you
don't get involved with this at all or
we just mix his little Batman films off
to the side it's really you know high
high quality art projects starring
Batman off to the side I hope he keeps
doing that because he's managed to avoid
it and I think God needs to learn the
lessons of what's worked and
realize that the fan base is there
they're just not interested in this big
connected universe
are you okay Paul
um I I was gonna finish my point there
but I coughed I would have just been
talking rubbish anyway let's be honest
James Condon watched this show uh but
yeah go and if you're watching it mate
just there's no there's no reason to
keep things tied into it make a hard
Choice Batgirl the whole thing and say
look this is damaging the brand having
these constant bombs back to back it
makes the audience less interested in
the next one because they're not getting
interested in the first film you just
need to cut it there launch with
Superman Legacy say this is a brand new
thing you've never seen it before it's
not connected to that new universe it's
its own thing we're bringing them back
baby soups is back they needed to do I
thought with the way he's talked about
how flash would restart the universe and
be
essentially like a segue into what we're
getting maybe it's Aquaman 2 I don't
know I thought they were going to do
what Flashpoint did in the comics which
was yeah we're really resetting this
[__] now yeah and
it doesn't it does not end on that note
at all it just makes it a little bit
more questionable so yeah I agree with
you
um
that like there there could have been a
way to where you you could but the more
you separate from it as sad as it is
that's the only way you can go at this
point but yeah man yeah like even even
now guess what's trending I go on
Twitter this is even my for you thing
this is genuinely trending fire James
good and bsfrin and then they've got
pictures of him at the premiere for The
Flash I don't even know if if I was him
I don't even know if I'd be going to
these premieres and stuff because you're
associating sorry you're associating
yourself with this brand that right
you're also being like we're getting rid
of it mate we're getting rid of all this
crap there's no way they're making a
flash too now there's no way they're
bringing back Ezra Miller I mean if they
drop the rock one of the biggest stars
in the world they drop the rock over the
Black Adam box office uh then yeah this
is it I mean
crazy it's crazy to think that we could
have had a Henry Cavill versus Black
Adam The Rock Superman film and and
they've you know they're doing Creature
Commandos instead but I'm not being
negative Nancy on it I'll promise I'll
not be that I'm excited for to see what
James Gunn does I hope it's worth the
sacrifices that he's made and I
appreciate you guys sacrificing an hour
of your time to listen to Broder shovel
just a disclaimer of being I've been at
work for 50 with 16 hours an hour going
on got up at 6am this morning uh powered
through and I was now I was nearly
finished and then uh they released well
the Craven trailer leaked and I thought
oh I'm gonna have to go back to work
because knowing Sony this will be
officially released in an hour's time
and good set you watch what's funny as
you message me or like I need to prep
this in case it releases and I had a
thought of
ah it's probably not gonna release yeah
it sure enough I was like Paul was right
on the money all over again you're right
on the money
yeah
you're good so yeah hope you guys have
enjoyed it this is episode four we've
made it four episodes and thank you for
your continued support I've just been
looking on the the analytics there if
people joining up becoming members and
supporting the channel which we we
really appreciate last week we had a bit
of controversy
um you know as soon as we stop recording
I I did feel like oh you know I feel
like we kind of
mishandled the way that we spoke about
things then and I mean I've been texting
Greg most days saying um and I feel
really shitty about that uh so yeah
apologies guys if you felt let down by
us on that as well
um so yeah we appreciate you appreciate
you coming back if you if you have come
back you might not even be listening to
this mate which you'll never know but I
should have kicked it off with this Paul
I should have you know what I mean but
now it feels more sincere because I'm
doing it at the end when it's yeah you
know what I mean I'm not just trying to
get Goodwill at the start of the the
episode I'm genuinely saying it from the
bottom of my heart it's on my mind and
I'd rather we at least address it and I
I apologize to you guys
you know I think touchy subjects like
that should be
handled with more respect and uh more
graceful than what we did
I'm gonna put the blame all on you I
just follow you that's all you well
you've just ruined my sincere thing with
a joke there and we're gonna get in
trouble again so I think it's a good
place to end
yeah well thank you uh guys Greg won't
be back next week don't worry about that
no damn yeah you're talking about next
week yeah it causing even more trouble
that guy Lydia he's he has seen he put a
video before saying that he hasn't seen
The Flash and he's just there celebrated
bombing because James Gunn made fun of a
month to her I was like oh Greg sorry
Josh Josh you're crazy you're crazy
Isaac he's a nice guy Josh I I actually
realized this week like I had a bit of a
moment of self-reflection thinking I
come across like a bit of a [__] on
Twitter you know
um so yeah apologies for that as well I
put our tweet before just saying look
I've realized I've came across like a
bit of a [__] I do enjoy comic book
movies and I'm open to anyone's
suggestions on how we can improve this
podcast as well
so yeah thanks guys thank you guys
appreciate you know and all sincerity
thank you guys for listening yeah means
a lot yeah and
just know we had no actual ill will or
intention about it and we know that even
if we make a joke about a sensitive or
controversial subject that we should at
the very least follow it up with well
here's what we really mean there's
there's ways to make humor and there's a
way to have humorous commentary without
it coming across insensitive if that
makes sense so that was not yeah yeah
sometimes we're rushing when we're doing
these and we just didn't think it all
out all the way through so I think as
well just you know like you do kind of
have to get put in check sometimes as
well and it can be oh my God a positive
thing for people to be like look mate
you're out of line there because
everyone's really respectful about it to
be honest though and it was more just us
kind of feeling like we let ourselves
down uh when we we should have spent
more time actually analyzing all sides
and instead of just going down this one
rabbit hole and then making crap jokes
about it so yeah apologies guys but uh
thanks for coming back if you made it
this far no we appreciate the love and
you know what it's nice seeing you guys
actually interacting with us and and
giving your thoughts on the podcast
because we could just be speaking to no
one there much appreciated
thanks for choosing us for your favorite
podcast Asia tricky in the end I got you
well cross the spoilerverse complete
number four
yeah we'll be back next week to talk
about more terrible crap that's probably
happened in the week so yeah what do you
mean the entire DC has been canceled
nah thanks guys and see you next week
peace peace